Hey, a jad here. It's been an incredible, incredible, hmm.
[inaudible] hey jad here. This has been,
it's been an amazing year here at radio lab. You guys, ah, guys,
what am I like the buddy. Okay. Hey Jad here.
It's been an incredible year at radio lab. You guys have made it a special year.
You've shared and supported the work of these. I'm just reading.
I don't even know what these words mean anymore. Hey, Jen.
Jen. Yeah. Okay. Their button. You can, can you man, can you do this?
Okay. [inaudible] I mean, that's, can you, can you,
can you say something that makes the case? I'm just,
it's not happening right now for me.
I thought you'd never ask.
Good. Can I squeeze and squeeze in here? But yeah. All right. Yeah. Good. Yeah,
I'll just, I'll be here.
Hey, I'm Dylan Keith. I'm the director of sound design for radio lab.
Usually on the other side of the glass. Uh, I just want to take a minute and,
uh,
play a few clips that are examples of the incredible work that the producers and
reporters here at Radiolab have done over the last year or so.
Hopefully to remind you of why we think that this show is worth your support.
Uh, 2017 has been a hell of a year for,
for everyone that I know actually just nuts.
And at radio lab we've expanded in all kinds of different ways and we've done
our best to go after stories that are deeper and newer and even out of our
comfort zone.
So the first clip I want to play for you is from a story about a man named
Oliver sipple who saved President Ford's life back in the 70s and then became
sort of a tragic footnote in American history.
And when you're trying to do a radio story about somebody who died a long time
ago, um, if you can't find that essential tape of that person,
sometimes it kills the story completely because we need that person to be
present in the narrative.
And you want to build the rest of the story around that specific tape.
And we found this incredible tape of Oliver that most people had never heard
before. Uh, there was just incredibly moving and we dug it.
It took forever to dig this tape up. And um,
and then we built the whole piece around it and it was just, uh,
it was just a beautiful experience. So here's part of that. Well,
I think you all know this is all ever simple.
We shaped the president's side as a prepared statement on a subject that's
appeared in the press today. In the past few days,
I have been asked many questions having to do with my sex show
preference as to what I have been asked, whether or not I am gay or homosexual.
This is, there is, this is my reply to the line in question.
The first reason
you are interested in my,
in me is the fact the woman who tried to shoot the president,
she, I'm sorry, I'm still nervous. Excuse me.
My orientation has nothing at all to do with saving the president's life.
I'm first and foremost a human being who enjoys and respects life.
I feel that a physician person toward worth is determined by how he or she
responds to the world in which they live,
not on how or what or with whom a private life is share.
So the next story I want to play is just, um, you know,
one that because I'm a cold work head, um,
just gave me chills from the moment we started reporting it when I was thinking
about sound designing it and scoring it.
I put in the creepiest feelings that I had from my childhood. Uh,
and it's about the history of the chain of command, which still exist today, uh,
regarding who has the power to start a nuclear war. And actually for this one,
I'll play the sort of movie trailer version that, uh,
I love to make for these episodes on the next radio lab.
I assumed that there had to be some sort of check and balance so that one man
couldn't just order the launch, a nuclear weapon,
the fate of humanity to not rest on one person.
He could launch the kind of a devastating attack. The world's never seen.
He doesn't have to check with anybody. He doesn't have to call the congress,
he doesn't have to check with the court.
He has that authority because of the nature of the world we live in.
That's in the next radio lab.
So this last one I want to play for you really quickly involved earthquakes and
babies and plane rides. A truck load of translators,
a marketplace that connected Ukrainian eggs with Israeli sperm.
It was just bananas.
Here it is on the next radio lab we have nine nine babies.
We need the increasingly complicated business of making a family,
two guys and three women, four countries, planes,
planes to wait Japanese to have thousands of dollars and the women behind it,
all the women up there in charge of deciding how they want their life to be and
we don't have to look at them with pity.
[inaudible].
If you have valued reporting from the radio lab crew in 2017 I'm asking you to
make an end of year tax deductible donation now to support our work for the next
12 months.
Your year end donation of just $60 combined with the support of other listeners
will really help us plan for the year to come. Go to
radiolab.org/donate to give or even easier. Just text the word,
give two seven zero one zero one to get started.
A simple form will pop up and you can donate in a matter of a second so please
support more stories, more voices, more Radiolab.
What do you think, Jed? Is that all right? Yeah.
I'll tell you I feel I feel Boyd with energy. Suddenly. Look man,
if you like Radiolab, you want of it. More ambitious
stories told in more ambitious ways will. This is how we pay for it.
To go to
radiolab.org/donate that's radiolab.org/donate or even faster.
Just text the word, give to the number seven oh one oh one this is,
that's the word.
Give to the number seven oh one oh one takes just a few seconds.
Tax Deductible. It's so fast. You can do it even before this promo is over.
Anyhow. Nice. Dylan. Thanks man.
Yeah. Uh, I'm kind of getting used to the mic here. Wait a second. Cut.
Happy New Year everyone and thanks for supporting radio lab.
We really couldn't do this without the listeners who give take care.
Oh wait, you're listening. Okay.
No. [inaudible]
you are listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S. E. Yup. Okay. Ready?
Three two, one. Hey, I'm Jad Abu Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and this is part two of our attempt to answer some listener
questions that have piled up over the years gathering digital dust in our inbox
and a few of them in this round come from kind of close to home. Yeah.
In any case,
starting us off this round is a question asker who has developed quite a
reputation here at radio lab. The other moveable Scott Little,
I'm just a normal dude, man.
Scott spoke to our producer, lots of Nasr.
Now, Scott, he actually sent us a lot of questions that caught our attention.
Yeah, they don't, they don't stop. I can't slow this brain down.
Questions like [inaudible]
truly do not even remember like writing.
Why is the moon devoid of all colors?
But when I read them I was like, oh yeah, that sounds like me.
Have we seriously not translated any animal languages yet?
Is there a reason coconuts look a lot like shoe pansy heads or is that just a
coincidence?
But then we zeroed in on one of Scott's questions that at first seem kind of
simple but it got really big.
Okay. When a spacial goes into space,
how do they make sure it doesn't hit any satellite?
Is it just radar or is there some kind of complicated system that tracks all of
them? And since we talked, just kind of looking up about this, you know,
about like how many satellites are actually up there and what are we even
calling space junk and, and has this affected anything yet?
Um, you know, it's just like,
it goes from like kind of informational to like almost like this sort of doom
and gloom real fast. Like there's so much junk up there,
like it's going to be impossible to leave the earth's atmosphere pretty soon.
And I don't know, I just, it just kind of me curious.
I'd be curious to see what, what's um, who's, who's in charge of all this?
That's what I want to know. Who's in charge here? Who's in charge of space.
Okay. Is everybody there? Yeah, I'm here.
I've got Colonel Walsh and she's willing to talk to you about space
surveillance. Okay, great. Ma'Am. You still hear us? Yes,
I'm here
so I couldn't actually find anyone who is literally in charge of space,
but I did find what I think is pretty much the next best thing.
Oh, Lieutenant Colonel Mia Walsh and I'm the commander of the 18th Space Control
Squadron.
I think your title has gotta be the coolest title of anyone I've ever
interviewed.
My title is the coolest title. The commander of the 18th Space Control Squadron.
Yeah, that's like the, you should, you should have like an action figure.
I think that would be amazing. Really very tiny actions.
Okay, so, so let's start from the top. When a space shawl goes into space,
how do they make sure it doesn't hit any satellites?
Well, we keep track of what's called the space catalog,
which is like a giant log book of all the manmade stuff surrounding us in outer
space.
A little over 23,000 objects.
Oh Wow.
So when whenever there's a launch, anything manned or unmanned,
we'll track it against the existing things in the catalog and we'll make sure
that it doesn't hit anything on the way up
or make sure it doesn't hit anything while it's up there.
And then if there is a chance of an actual collision, they send out an alert.
The notifications we create are called conjunction data messages [inaudible].
So we send several thousand of those every day.
Why?
Well thousand. We have a, a more refined,
what we call emergency criteria and we issue between six and 10 of those per
day.
What? That's like a, that's a lot.
It seems high. But when you consider we're tracking 23,000 objects,
if it's not too bad,
but on top of those 23,000 objects, it turns out there's,
there's even more stuff out there.
But she says it's basically just too small to be able to track.
We think that they're probably more like a half a million close to a half a
million on [inaudible].
Why, what, what? So you have like almost none of them,
it sounds like that,
but just remember that some of those [inaudible] hundred thousand objects are
very, very tiny pieces of debris.
So like give me a sense like how big, how small, what are we? Yeah,
what are we talking about?
There is small as, as sizes of um, flecks of paint.
Oh Man.
So there's no way you can track like a half a million flecks of pain that feels
like, that feels like impossible.
No. And actually if you Google space shuttle and Fleck of paint,
you can see a pretty famous picture of this shuttle window that was hit by a
fleck of pain and the kind of damage that it can do. [inaudible]
tell me what kind of damage you can do moving at that speed. What, what yeah,
what, what would I see if I saw that picture?
So it went through several layers of the shuttle window and they determined that
it was from a flick of paint from just, you know, a tiny fleck.
So you've got almost half a million pieces of this itty bitty space junk.
And when it comes to that stuff,
it's really just a matter of keeping our fingers crossed and monitoring the
situation so that we can react to it if something happens.
Okay. Well, so, so, so when I, when I called, um, this listener,
he's like, he's a little bit um, paranoid. Uh,
and then the one interesting
thing I, I came from, this is this thing, I think it's called the,
the Kessler Syndrome. I would, it is thing the castle Lelo effect.
That's what it is. So there's this,
NASA scientists got this thing named after him where he's like,
we might get to a point where we have so much stuff in space that like something
will collide with,
with like two satellites will collide and that collision will cause so much
debris that it will basically be like this giant thing where just like things
are just exploding around the earth for like years and years and years,
like some sort of willow guest plague of space, job
swarmed with a locust plague of space junk and that it'll be impossible to leave
the earth's atmosphere anytime soon. What would you say to Scott
[inaudible] just a second. Yes, this is Steve. You know, we, we have,
we have a job to, to track those objects,
but a question like that is,
is this kind of out of our realm of responsibility?
Okay. Okay, no problem. Um, uh, well let, see, can I,
and just let me ask you another question then. Tell me if you can't answer it,
that's fine too. Um, which is,
he also brought up something called the Caslow effect. Do you know about that?
Or have you heard of that before?
W
which is,
which is the idea that there's a possibility that two satellites will collide
and then they'll create debris and then that'll make a domino effect and cause
all kinds of other collisions and then it'll be a,
a whole giant debris field.
I'm sure we've heard of it. The Kepler effect.
Oh, Kessler, sorry about that. Yeah, we're very familiar with the concept. Yeah.
And is that something you worry about or no?
Hello? Hello?
Hello.
I guess it is a concern. Sure. But, um,
I think the members of the squadron do such a great job tracking everything
that's up there that we would hope that that wouldn't happen.
All right.
Not that not the answer I was hoping for. Yeah. We, me neither. I gotta admit I,
I started this whole thing thinking that Scott's fear was like kind of crazy.
But then after that conversation I started, you know,
researching it for real and I online, I found this video of Kessler himself,
the beginning of the space program, there was a general attitude.
The space was a big sky,
but you could put anything in it that you wanted and not fill it up to the
problem that you quickly run it.
He basically says exactly what, Scott,
you don't change the way we operate in space.
All this results in an exponentially increasing amount of degree until all
objects are reduced to a cloud of orbiting fragments that are capable of
destroying any spacecraft
tends to operate. You are within that cloud, which would mean no satellites,
no weather satellites, no gps, no any other kinds of satellites.
And then in the future, if things go really badly,
uh,
you know,
we'd just be stuck here forever and ever on earth.
Yeah. Our next question comes from this guy in Brooklyn and he is five, five,
five, five, five, five, five, five, five. That would be five, five years old.
And I interviewed him. [inaudible] are you going to go in my kitchen?
Who are you TG? I name is cage and I'm your son. Okay.
Tell me your question.
My question is why is the earth called earth?
Why is the earth called earth? I don't know. Why do you have any guesses?
A of kiss came up with the name.
The earth came up with its own name, I think. Okay.
Should I found out and then tell you yes.
My first stop was a guy named Peter. Yeah. This is Peter. Peter Barry.
I'm a isotope geochemist. I work at the University of Oxford.
I'm a researcher here.
Am I right that you have some kind of a loose affiliation with NASA or is that,
is that not right?
Very loose in the sense that, I mean, I do a little bit of planetary work.
I've worked on some lunar samples in the past.
But you've worked on lunar samples. Yeah.
So I've actually done some, some isotope work on lunar samples.
He's actually one of the few people on the planet who's held the moon in his
hand. So here's my question. I think it's pretty simple,
but maybe there's a story there. I don't know.
The question comes from Taiji vme his dad.
Why is the earth called the earth?
That's a really interesting question. The earth is actually, so this is, uh,
and it's an old Saxon word derive from English.
Dramatic roots in German earth has said, ah,
Erda I believe if I say earth and in German, and of course all these,
all these words are originally derived from like a, a mother language,
like an Indo European mother language.
But what it means in German and what it means in all those old languages is it
actually just means soil or ground.
Oh Huh.
All the other planets, all the other visible planets have these really,
you know, awesome names and they're all named after Roman gods.
I mean, you have mercury's,
it moved really quickly around the sun.
So we got it name from the Roman Messenger. God. Then you have
Venus chose this bright, beautiful orb glowing in the sky.
So we named it after the goddess of love and of course, Mars,
which was fiery and red. And so we named it after the God of war.
An earth is the only planet, which is it named after a Roman God.
Clearly this much different,
uh, uh, etymology.
Peter Ultimately referred me to another guy at Oxford.
I love it.
Assist. Hi, can I speak to Gabe please?
Hi, speaking. Yeah. Hi Dad,
this is Gabriel Berry.
I can tell you a bit about, um, who the protests in day Europeans probably were.
Sure. Um,
Kroto pro toe Indo Europeans. Yes. So, so,
so basically what Gabriel Barry told me is that you could find,
you could trace all this whole thing,
the word or back to this group of people who lived
maybe 6,000 days ago.
This is like way before JC, way before the Greeks or the Romans. Yep.
Criteo and a European lived in basically what's now eastern Europe.
So these were really people from the steps of Russia.
Don't know a lot about them. We know they moved around a lot. Yeah.
Well and nomadic people couldn't, for whatever reason, settle down.
But he says at some point, maybe about 5,000 years ago,
moved from the steps of eastern Europe and Russia and
swept into Europe.
It seems they trove chariot and they came on horseback,
make huge wave, uh,
unsettled ood away from Britain down to northern India.
So imagine this, uh,
this wave of people on horseback spreading all over Europe and into India and
speaking this language,
they would ultimately branch out into English and German and French and Hindi
and Portuguese and like 400 some odd languages
they spread across Europe and across, down into India and Iran.
The thought is they started to slow down, settle down,
and that's when they became farmers.
And that's when they started spending a lot of time looking down at the dirt.
We have lots of words for farming,
from protein to European words like plow farrow or, or, uh,
or as in the word that would become earth.
But at that early point it just meant dirt.
And presumably it just meant like this dirt,
this specific little piece of dirt right here.
And I'm plowing it somewhere along the way.
[inaudible]
that word or Herta
became the word for all dirt.
The whole ball of dirt. Basically,
the word that starts being used to ass becomes the same word is used for fam,
you know, Michelob and also, uh, quite often some sort of,
got it.
We have no idea when that switch happened. Exactly.
I mean, we know within a few thousand years,
but whenever it was, strikes me as a pretty important moment for us.
People can ask you some questions. Taiji.
When did you discover that Earth was a planet on it?
No. No, really. When did you discover, do you remember when you,
when you learned that the earth was a ball? When my last too.
You don't remember? Do you know?
You don't say do they don't last at little nest according to change.
I mean, I don't know. This is what I could get out of him.
That moment for him happened at daycare at this place called Little Nest
Brooklyn.
Yeah. Vanessa did it.
It was a day when his teacher, Vanessa had them do this little [inaudible]
the project. She said we were going to make up our own,
are pushing our own. What?
Our own person or what does that mean?
That means learning about the earth and nature.
Earth with two eyes and some legs and some Martins.
Oh, I see. I see.
They were basically making these earth puppets and he says, after they did that,
I was sending on the rock. You were sitting on the rug.
Is that where you have your best ideas?
You were sitting on this a little rainbow colored rug that they have holding
this earth puppet. I was thinking
[inaudible]
I was thinking of earth last round,
smooth round. And it's a plan.
By the time we get from the Prodo Indo Europeans to the ancient Greeks and
Romans, which is a couple thousand years,
you begin to see the concept of earth arising up.
It goes from a simple word that means dirt for soil,
[inaudible]
to mother earth, the goddess.
So it went in the opposite direction of the other planets.
It started as this lowly dirty thing beneath our B
and then became divine
[inaudible].
When I told th this answer, uh, he was disappointed.
He was actually hoping that the earth was named by an Alien Daddy.
Nothing. I asked to go to another question. Yeah, you got another one.
Go ahead.
How has the son made you mean like how, how did the sun become the Sun
man? That's another good question.
Yeah,
I know. I was just repeating it so I can understand it.
Are you asking me how it was on board?
[inaudible]
do you ever look at someone and wonder what is going on inside their head?
You do? What? What? What? What? How does he know that? I mean, yeah, of course.
Why is he special? Hey, sorry. I'm going to get licensed.
My Brain Ram BFF is best friends forever. What is BFO? That's the friends often.
Okay. Yup. Are you ready? Yup. Are you ready? I am all already.
You see what I'm doing? But are you doing just Dunkin donuts? Has It? Maybe? No,
no, no. Like, like here in, they have people
come in that I think somebody comes with a truck. What do you do with it? Wait,
you have done it before? How did they do that?
I don't even understand that question.
Yeah, she should tell Simon the, we're in here. Hey everybody,
I'm gonna help you next up. Yes. Just to seeing your coffee. Black please. Hi.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. The Adler family
as in producer, Simon Adler and his dad, Tim. Yep. Uh,
so a couple of weeks back,
I'm just heading out of town now. I asked my old man,
my dad to record himself going on a drive.
All good road trips deserved a cup of coffee and being the frugal individually,
but I am.
I decided that I drive through it of McDonald's would be the appropriate place
to fuel up.
He and my mom lived in Northwestern Wisconsin in a small little city town called
Auclair. I'm going to drive country roads in specifically.
What I'd asked him to do was to go drive on the county highways just outside of
town, farm field areas.
There are very few cars on the road that I'm on.
And the reason I asked him to do this with,
because for as long as I can remember, he's had this nagging
question, a question that he bombards me with every time
home
off times when we're talking on the phone, he'll bring it up. Can you hear me?
Yeah. Over the dinner table. Over email. I mean,
I've heard about this at least 600 times. What does mom think about all this?
I've never asked him.
Oh, hi. Oh no, she just rolls her eyes.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah.
So what's happening?
Yeah. So do you want me to tell you why, uh, why I'm recording?
Or do you want me to just,
I knew we would get to it so you can tell me now.
I thought maybe it was going to be like a puzzle that I had to figure out.
Okay. Well let me, let me just prompt you with this and see it.
See how well you take the bait here.
Do you know the question I'm talking about and could you just tell me what that
question is?
The question is, well let me back up.
And example is this,
a person will be riding a road bike down a lonely country road.
Two other people will be walking their dog on the side of the road and a semi
trailer truck will then be coming down that road.
Okay.
So we've got three different actors here and nobody else from miles and miles
and miles.
And there is not, you haven't, the biker hasn't seen another car,
truck or pedestrian four miles on this road.
But what will happen is all three of those actors will come together at the
exact same point and the exact same time
creating a dangerous situation first of all,
but then it's just this spark and then it diffuses and you could sit on that
stretch of road for six more years and not find that happen.
And the key thing here, my dad says is he it Tim Adler, uh, witnesses,
this sort of thing.
Oh, it happens to me a lot all the time.
I would say it happens once every two weeks
upcoming. We have the possibility of an event
on the day I sent him to record himself. Uh, after 10 or 15 minutes,
have not seen a single other car on the road, came around this bend,
there's a manure wagon being driven by a tractor right down the road.
And yes,
we hear here at all appens the manure wagon is going down the road.
A tractor has just been pulled out on the road and now I'm passing by and all
three happened at the exact same place.
It just happens.
What is your question then? Is it? Why does that happen or is it,
the question is why does this happen to me and does it seem to happen to others
as well?
[inaudible]
okay. I think it's quite complicated.
I don't know if it does your father get the thing to get to the bottom of this?
We call it the man who we thought might just have the answer. I'm a professor.
I'm actually professors, Sir David Spiegelhalter.
Where did you say your professor, Sir? Does that mean you've been knighted?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You're a knight. You're the,
you're the first night I've ever spoken to. I'm on it.
I nothing but Cambridge is stuffed full of, there's hundreds. There's three.
A penny round here. The probability of me talking to a, yeah,
you got to get exactly right. Very hard at date. Yeah.
Professor Sir David is a statistician. We're pretty dull with him.
When I ran my old man's question by him, his response,
I get quite a lot of stories like this.
People contact me and they get very anxious, in fact, because they feel it.
Something's going on in their lives that making things happen all the time.
They're getting signs from the environment around them. Okay. I mean,
the term is, it's noticed synchronicity,
[inaudible]
synchronicity,
you know, that all of these big Buddha faculties of the psyche,
that was the term that Carl Young invented for this.
The division's entirely confined to, to space and time.
Carl Gustaf Union, you know, the fame to psychoanalyst of the 20th century.
You can have dreams or visions of the future. Yeah.
The idea that there was actually some force behind nature that we didn't
currently recognize that did drive these things to happen.
Something beyond the normal rules of physics, quotes,
rationality. Hmm. So he really believes that there was this external force.
I think he just wasn't a very good statistician because Sir David says,
when you start to look at the events in our lives,
in terms of their probability,
every single event that happened to us is unbelievably unlikely and
unpredictable. So the crucial thing that measures it sort of surprising,
this is the unlikeliness of it occurring at some point over a reasonable period
in just a, I don't know, I'm trying to make this as concrete as possible.
So good luck. So if you're driving down a street that has, I don't know,
three cars per 10 miles and two bikers per 10 miles,
like how likely is it that over the course of those 10 miles you're going to
intersect the way that he does,
the likelihood of that happening in any particular 10 miles or any particular
hour is very low. It's a surprising event. But if your father drives a lot,
the likelihood of it happening over, I don't know,
maybe a week or two weeks and your month is very high. So David says, uh,
think of it this way.
So let's say my dad would consider one of these intersections to be a meaningful
coincidence, a synchronous event.
If a semi truck in a biker pass him
within five seconds of each other. Now
if in one hour of driving my dad sees 15 cars and five bikers,
the map tells you that the likelihood of one of each,
uh, both a car and a bike passing him in the same a five second window,
it's about one in 7,000.
But think of how many of those five second windows there are in any given week
or month. Uh, in fact,
I think of each of these five second windows as like one spin of a roulette
wheel,
a giant roulette wheel with 7,000 different numbers that you could bet the ball
would land on your badge. Now Ladies and gentlemen,
and this is key when my dad's driving,
it's not like he only gets one spin of the wheel or one chance to see one of
these synchronous events instead lays your bench, ladies and gentlemen,
it's like every five seconds he gets to try again.
And given that he drives like three hours a week, when you do the math,
what you end up with is a 31% chance of him experiencing this in any given week.
Meaning, if he's looking for it,
he should definitely expect to see one of these at least once a month.
So you have to not look at just the event,
not just the particular thing your father observed.
You have to think of all the chances for those things to occur that didn't
occur. You know, you've got to think of all the stuff you're not seeing.
Yeah, a pretty good.
See that fish quite the fish is like his third cast and
I called my dad back to break the news to him. All right. You want the answer?
Yes.
So a weaker explained it to him from the history of viewing to the fact that
he's really just got to pay attention to all the times these coincidences aren't
happening. Right. And when you look at it from that angle,
it's statistically to be expected
there. I understand,
I understand. It's a little hard to swallow.
I'm a little more human than most
it is.
Does make sense from a statistical analysis.
But why does it keep happening to me?
So these things do happen to some people.
And I've got a lot of admiration of these people because they, your fans,
obviously great man. You know, it does tend to happen to people who,
who are very sensitive and aware and they notice their environment.
They're actually very mindful people that happens to,
and I suppose what I'm saying is this is a really admirable, you know,
characteristic trait.
Well,
there is no question this makes my day when I've heard that I've been praised
by, I'm nice.
Yeah.
Kelly, his highness that someday we should go out for a cup of tea.
Not to bring it down though. He heaped all this praise on you.
I'd love to meet him and I'm sure he's wonderful, but then concluded by saying,
but I would, I think I would say that he's not very special.
I'll, I, you didn't really have to tell me that. Yeah, sorry.
No, that's okay. That I'm going to just listen to the first part.
Okay.
All right. Okay. Enjoy the rest of the day of the week. Thanks.
I love you and I'll talk to [inaudible]. Tell Mama, give her a call. And, uh,
hopefully tomorrow morning. [inaudible] fine. Love you too. Okay, bye bye.
[inaudible]
your home for emcare news and classical music.
89.3 WPT in Green Bay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I want to ask you one question. Alright,
excellent question. [inaudible] just relax. Can you w you are,
we're not in Kansas anymore.
[inaudible] where do I go?
You know, where you, how did you get any
[inaudible] [inaudible] stop.
Okay. So mixed up.
Yeah. My name is Eben Becker.
We're going to go to Boston with Evan Becker. And here's his question.
So I grew up in the Boston area. I still live in Boston today.
Kind of relevant to this question is
Evan, it turns out is something of a snowboarder. Yep.
You know, I've been snowboarding for 20 plus years or so and friends and I, uh,
traditionally go up to, uh, New Hampshire, Vermont, you know,
New England area to go skiing
and you know, a many years back on one of these group trips they took,
uh, we, we were feeding and um,
they had recently opened a no tubing course
[inaudible] and by the way, that tiny [inaudible],
that's our producer Tracy Hunt [inaudible]
and, uh,
everybody's looking at the snow tube chorus and some would just pose the
question of like, how fast do you think that's been goes? Um,
and then another friend jumped in and said like,
I bet you I could get that up to like a hundred miles an hour easily from the
top of the mountain. And like,
no way that you couldn't even do that in perfect conditions.
And from this small little disagreement,
the great debate began from there. And like, that was in 2004.
Oh my God.
Been going on for more than a decade.
And over these 10 years going back and forth and back and forth on this
question.
Evan and his friends gradually focused in on the rules of this argument and
eventually they came on this very specific wording.
So the question is, um,
in perfect conditions within the earth's atmosphere and not within a vacuum and
you reach 100 miles per hour going down a mountain on an everyday snow too,
like an inner tube,
the same thing that you get if you went to the local hardware store or something
like that. Nothing fancy, nothing overly engineered, things like that.
And still to this day, some of Evan's friends are like, yeah,
we can break a hundred miles an hour. We can, but Evan,
I just don't see that it can happen.
He says, no,
you can not do this,
but I think it can happen. I think it can happen.
That is Destin Sandlin host
of an extremely popular youtube channel called, Hey, it's me, Destin,
welcome back to smarter every day. And this is important,
smarter every day cause he is very smart on his channel.
But Destin does is he proposes.
So you've probably observed that cats almost always land on their feet.
Questions. Today's question is why questions a lot like Evans,
which he then proceeds to answer. I mean are do, she does GG the stunt cat.
I think that's in your also an actual rocket scientist. A little bit.
I've only, I've only said that one time. My mom corrected me very quickly.
She was like, no, I, I'm a, I'm what's called a flight test engineer.
So we, we test missiles and helicopters and stuff like that.
What can I say one thing before we start? Uh, sure.
I feel like before we jumped to the answering part of this conversation,
I want to appreciate the question. So I'm just,
I'm wondering is there some like physical,
are there some physical reasons why a hundred would be really hard to do in an
inner tube down a hill? Yes. So this is what I,
I thought about when I first heard the question.
So if you think about going down a hill,
there's two things that are slowing you down.
The first one is the friction with the snow.
And the second one is the air resistance,
which for Destin all boils down to something that he calls drag.
It's a one half times the density of the aims, the Coefficient of drag,
the cross sectional.
So this started as a really simple question in my mind and as I started gaming
out how to, how to do this without killing a person,
the more I thought about it, the more I realized it can get very,
very complicated. Yeah. I mean I can, I can show you all those equations,
but I can't work them out on the back of an envelope.
Mostly because math is hard still.
He did tell us that he could,
he was pretty confident that he could get this tube to go down more than a
hundred miles an hour down the hill. Yes. I'm saying that it can happen.
And Are we sure that somebody hasn't done this and posted like their GoPro video
on youtube,
this world record or gravity powered snow slut. Whoa. What is that?
Whoa. What's the, what's the world record? She's passing me the phone. Um,
okay. So at this moment, Destin's wife, terra Sandlin,
she's in the studio cause she's with him on vacation in New York and she's been
looking at her iPhone at the Guinness World Records website,
gravity powered snow sled,
134 kilometers per hour. Wait, that's over a hundred.
That's 83 points. That's under 80 power.
He said, I'm over here questioning everything about what I believe.
I mean this is the moment for me.
A sled is meant for velocity a to be faster.
Oh Man. Miles an hour. We're too slow here. So,
so here's the deal. I'm different than most people.
I'm not going to die in this foxhole if it's clear that I'm wrong.
If it's clear that I'm wrong, I'm going to retract. Okay?
So here's where I would go with this. This is what I would do.
The real big thing that the tube causes a problem in my mind is all the friction
on the, on the mountain, right?
So I mean within the bounds of the question, because he,
he went to all these great links to define what we could do and what we
couldn't. He did not tell us what slope the mountain had to be on.
And so what we're going to do is we're going to go to the worst possible
mountain imaginable, which is straight down a cliff basically. Okay.
Are we all on the party line? And so with the help of producer Tracy Hunt,
Evan and Destin Cajon, I heard Evan, can you hear me? Yeah,
we wanted Evan the question or do you hear or how Destiny's gonna work this
thing out. Good. We're all together
right here what the answers are.
Yeah. So this is ultimately a question about terminal velocity, right?
So in theory,
if we were to go straight down like out of an airplane,
we would go as fast as we could ever go because the only thing contributing to
the terminal velocity at that point would be drag no friction at all.
And so would you accept the answer?
If I'm able to go a hundred miles per hour straight down out of an airplane,
for example, would you say that it is possible? Maybe even if our,
you know, even our far hill is only one degree off of, you know,
straight down towards the earth, it still counts as the hill, right?
Yeah, I guess so. You know?
Yeah. As long as it's going downhill in your fat miss fear. Yeah.
So I I want to call, uh, I've got a buddy named Paul here in Alabama.
He owns a place called skydive, Alabama.
I go to church with him and see him all the time and uh, I think you'd be game.
So is that, could you, could you Destin like uh, I don't know, like two way.
Call him from your phone or something. Is that what you,
what you think you're going to try to do? Yeah.
So Paul [inaudible]. So here we go. What's up man?
Are you ready for me to merge you all right, Paul, are you there?
Yes sir.
Oh, oh. Hi Paul. Okay.
How's it going?
And we have Evan who had this, who had this crazy question about snow tubing.
So Paul, let me, let me kind of set the stage here. Okay.
So Destin explains the whole inner tube thing and he tells his friend Paul like
we want to know is if you can jump out of a plane, go streak down,
could you break the a hundred miles per hour barrier? Is that safe?
Can you do a test like that?
Well, yeah, it's totally possible. I've done it.
Wait,
um,
you've done it with an inner tube.
Absolutely. And a rat. It's all full size, Huh?
What? Yeah. Plus is that on two different occasions,
he and a bunch of friends jumped out of an airplane carrying an inflatable
flotation device, uh, in one hand. And they can, I had a watch,
a little computer that track their speed on the other. How fast did you go?
Um, in both cases it was over 120.
Really? [inaudible] but yes,
it's 100% possible.
So that it doesn't count. It does, it does that it's the same.
It's as if it's as if he had a virtual mountain that he jumped off of the
question specifically said on the mountain. Like,
these guys have been arguing about this for a decade. Right.
And we're going to come back to them and be like, no, no,
just drop it out of an airplane. No, this cheating. No,
it doesn't resolve anything.
You can beat down a mountain and not touching them out. Sure. False.
That's where you go to law school. You went to stuff like that. Well,
did you read the question?
I am now here by recusing myself from this whole affair. Do we have, we have,
we have ceased to truly in good faith. Answer the question. What do you mean?
And furthermore,
we get the guy on the phone and we hood wink him into accepting a renegotiated,
uh, a contract here of the collections. No, that's, no, he got bullied. I am,
I would not be a party to this, but I, I know
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
how much you care.
Tell us where we're going next. So the next one, uh,
is from our producer and in QA. Oh, hello. Any, hello God.
What are we going to be talking about today? What is,
what question do you bring up?
Oh, okay.
So this one is a little bit different because it didn't come in the form of a
question.
It came in the form of a very tantalizing email from a fellow named Ern Hendrix.
Henry. Yes, from Amsterdam. Good morning. Hi, is this Erin? Yes, it's me.
I need to basically said, hey, am urn.
I'm an artist and I just want you all at Radiolab to know that me and my friend,
we are building an island.
Offsets are building an island of fat and I live in a fat. Yeah,
I know like I was like of all the things to build an island note of why fat,
I'm just fascinated by it. I just like thinking about it. Yeah.
Well what was like,
what's the thing that made you start looking at fat in a curious way?
What was the moment?
Well, the real moment,
the real moment was I sitting together with a friend of mine and Mike Thompson
and we are in a train and going to Amsterdam.
When we started talking about fat and that it was such a strange thing first and
why was there so much of it?
Were you eating fat or were you feeling fat or what? What? I mean,
we're weird guys, right? We talk about things like this,
probably eating fat like chips or fries or something.
And then we started talking about how in the English newspapers they had been
this new stories about Ed Burks,
these fat birds that are under the ground in the sewers of London,
just like wreaking havoc. And there was one guy that what? Timeout
that Berg.
It's actually in the Oxford dictionary since 2015 it's like an actual word now.
Fatberg in iceberg. Yeah, in the sewers. The sewers. Wow.
What do those look like? Well, I mean like a sort of,
imagine an iceberg I guess,
but this one's floating on the water in the tunnels underground in London and is
made entirely of of fat. Yeah.
And a little while ago urn and his friend Mike actually got to go down into the
sewers to check out these fabrics. [inaudible]
it was an amazing experience.
They're sort of like waiting through it with these weight or hip waders on,
pushing bits and pieces of fat aside.
It's just this strange sort of trembling of gooey stuff inside of the sewer.
Wait, yeah, let me look it up. Wait, it's, you have, is that a picture of it?
Of a Fatberg? Yeah. Oh my God. Wow. Yeah, so,
so it's like this like clumpy lumpy mass of garbagey fat stuff.
It's gray and Brown and it's sort of like filled with all this sewer stuff,
living it. Whoa.
Fungus grows on it
and it just like completely blocks the old brick tunnels underground.
So this is like, this is like based on the things people have eaten.
There's so much fat in people's Diet and the sewers. Yeah. It's just like,
it's like people throwing fat away, like taking bacon grease,
throwing it down the sink, cooking fat down the sink. What?
And in September of this year in London,
they found a Fatberg in the sewers that weighed as much as 11 double decker
buses. That's how much fat shut up. I know. It's crazy. In one place.
Yeah. And of course
course
engineers at the Thames Water company in Britain say they've launched a sewer
war against a giant fat Blob, clogging London's sewers.
The way it's described in the news.
That's always a monster fatty monsters ever be something positive.
It needs to be monitored. It needs to be settled.
Please call credit now familiar enemies. It has a bad rep,
but I mean are and felt like maybe fat isn't a monster.
Maybe it's just like this, this giant thing in the world that's,
that's trying to express itself.
He be like wants to be seen. If he wants to be on the stage on some appreciation
fat, trying to have a voice and say like, listen to me, I'm here.
Don't think I'm important. I am make up 20% of your body that Duh Dah, Dah,
Dah and celebrate fat does he is he was,
he is celebrating fat and so he said that, you know,
if as an artist you're trying to explore water,
you don't just drink it out of a glass.
We swim in the ocean. You left you a ride your bicycle through a rain storm.
This is where you start to appreciate watering is in a different
wait.
So he's trying to do the same kind of thing with that experience it and I'll be
different ways
to walk on it. We wanted to sort of make angels,
no angels. We're going to make tech angels. Um,
we just want to have this different relationship I guess.
And is that where he came up with the majestical idea of building a fat island?
That's right. Did he make, did he actually make one? Yeah. Yeah.
He's making one right now.
He's got like this like spot off the wharf in Amsterdam and right there in the
ocean water, he's building this little floating blob of fat
with matching federally and vendoring sets from a waste materials from the
butcher.
Sometimes you're just buying it and we're melting it and then pouring it onto
the islands making a bigger and bigger.
And right now it's like 15 feet across and it's just,
just like they're hanging out,
bobbing up and down and side to side. And it sort of, you know, it's alive.
It moves. It's, you know, it's always changing. So, um,
we give ourselves a maybe another half year or a year and then it should be
finished.
And could you, how actually, how big do you hope to get it?
Can you think of like as big as a truck or a blue whale or you're going a blue
whale?
No, no. Oh my God. That would be amazing.
Of course,
dreams are like that. My dream is that I wouldn't be able to see the end of it.
Oh Wow. Really realistic I suppose.
I mean, um,
the size of two or three trucks who'd be amazing already and then you have a
real thing. I mean, probably be able to stand on it. That's the thing.
I would like to be able to stand on it. That will be pretty good then.
Not then you can really safely call it an island somehow.
Definitely. Yeah. Yeah.
Great. I know it's strange, but, um,
what I noted, I love it. Yeah. I noted them when I'm there.
I really love the little sort of thing that is there in the water.
Do you have, if we were to use this as, as part of the show,
I need you to give me some kind of, um,
question that I can try and answer about fat. And it sounds like you are,
are doing a lot of questioning.
Well, I would really like to know when we're, like, I'm very, very,
very curious about the relationship between life and fence.
Was there first life or first set?
Okay.
Or, or even when did set starts because we know when certain species of animals
started and when the, we know more or less when the universe was created, right?
Yeah. When did that start? When was the first set? Okay.
This is something that I would love to know
when was the first five first. That's interesting. Yeah.
And actually it turns out that the very,
very first version of fat has been around for a pretty long time.
As long as our soldiers and around before.
Wow. So is this like big bang we're talking or,
well, no, it would have been after that. After star formed and exploded,
then you could start forming these.
Okay. So this is aqueous geochemist Tom McCall,
I admit, I am in my pajamas.
Oh, that's so great. You got a hold of him during the Thanksgiving week. Um,
so Tom told me that the earliest, earliest version of fat was
a carbon hydrogen oxygen compound
called
Oh yes,
fatty acid. Yep. Hydrogen, carbon, oxygen.
So first you need hydrogen and hydrogen comes along with the big bang.
So we get that really early. Um, then we have to wait for,
start a form, start to get old a started, die and explode.
And then you get carbon and oxygen and that carbon and oxygen along with the
hydrogen is now like sort of swirling around in this interstellar space,
dust stuff. And when those three things come together,
they start to make these, these shapes.
So we have like a chain of carbons linked together and each one of those carbon
has a couple of hydrogen bonded to it.
So you've got a carbon hydrogen chain. And then
at one end is a, what's called the carboxyl group.
And that's like a little group at the top. This carbon,
hydrogen and oxygen in it. Yeah.
So I like to think of it kind of like a flower.
Like the stem of the flower is hydrogen carbon or the petals of the flower
contain oxygen as well as carbon and hydrogen.
And there's fat in this little flower like shape long
before the earth existed, floating around in space.
So then the sun and the moon and the earth and the planets form and you've got
our solar system and on the surface of the earth after it's cooled,
you've got fatty acid. Now we don't know exactly how they got there,
whether they formed on the earth itself or came from,
I don't have an immediate right
smacking into earth. Um,
but the important thing is that fatty acids are there and there's also a lot of
water there.
And the water is important because the thing about these little fatty acids is
that
has have the hydrophobic end to the molecule.
So hide your phone phobic means like scared of water. So is it,
it is a first like water. Okay. So our fatty acid flowers,
the oxygen end, the um, the flower end,
that's the end that kind of likes water
in the stem end,
like your water.
And so if there's water, the stems are like cow, we need to get away from it.
And so all these flowers form this, you can imagine it like a,
a bouquet that is so full that it is a sphere.
So all the flowers are on the outside cause they love water and all the stems
are on the inside. They're hiding from the water. That's interesting.
So all the fat, the,
all the fat flowers join together because it allows the water hating parts to
hide. Yeah. And the watering loving parts to be on the surface. Yeah.
But this was all like long pre-life this is life is no idea what it is yet life
hasn't even thought about coming on the scene. Interesting.
But there is a theory, it's one of many theories out there,
but there's an idea that when these little fat flower bubbles form in this sort
of primordial sea, they're kind of taking
the little sample, the fluid it around them. Then
inside with them,
so whatever your fluid, right, it's going to get trapped inside the,
so on the inside they've got some things,
some visitors from visitors and the theory goes that maybe one of the things
around in the sea that ended up getting pulled inside,
one of those fat bubbles was a little floaty bit of genetic material like like a
little bit of RNA and then for the first time ever instead of random bits of RNA
floating around in a soupy sea you have a cell
[inaudible]
for the first time you have an inside, you have a,
you separate from the super round you,
so the fat ball, these fatty little threesomes.
If that floated in from outer space and Levy landed here and maybe look cool.
Where's the first container that made life possible? Right.
[inaudible]
I don't think there is any way really have anything like we call a living being
without having a membrane or something separated from this. Rounding
fat is really important. Profoundly important.
That is is without fat there would be no us there. We'd be healthy.
We we are, we are. We are built in houses a fet.
So that means when you get [inaudible]
your soap bar out in the shower, you should give it some respect is so fat.
Yeah, I think so. Yeah. It is bad, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. No traditional soap.
It's just fat. Yeah. Really? Yeah. Yeah. Shit, I didn't know that.
And that's okay. You don't know everything can, I mean,
but I think I'm actually really excited for [inaudible] to hear this because I
feel like I'm going what can convey the way that the beginning of life told him
that? No, I haven't. Can you hear me? Ooh, I wonder what he'll say. Alright.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. So I called on and again,
and this time she was at a conference,
well, my coats are covered in fat. Now I had to go to this conference.
I didn't know what was coach Fetty. Okay. I found an old coat.
But you know, everything is covered in set.
We get how this is taking over my life and I just have to deal with it.
Anyway. Um,
so I wanted to tell you what my scientist told me about the earliest form of
fat. Can I tell you? Yes, please. Okay.
So I'm trying to think of a way to put this succinctly. Okay.
So I told them everything I learned,
it makes a barrier barrier between us and the rest of the world.
It makes it makes us really, yeah. Yeah.
And it could be that these like these like early,
early fatty acids are the thing that make life as we know it,
possible
suspected it. I suspect it is. Yes.
Intuition. I guess it's beautiful how it's supposed to be.
This is what I've always dreamt of the Burke starts to generate as soon as I'm
in love and sort of so nice that we're not telling me things that I don't know.
This is what, this is why I lived every moment.
Okay.
[inaudible]
thanks guys. Okay. Yeah. Nice.
A lot of people do think, uh, for this, uh, these two episodes,
this was actually a real group effort, but particular props to producers,
Tracy hunt in that Keel. Tiefer Yep.
You're heading the whole thing into Bethel and to Bethel hop tay for a huge
production assist it should.
You have a question that's burning in your brain. We know exactly.
Send it to us at radio lab at [inaudible] dot org and also a cro, which a w NYC.
Dot. She likes to get them particularly,
not particularly send that directly and a this box.
He does particularly like it when you stand on the sidewalk or just outside his
window. Say, I'm furious with curiosity.
I told because I'm on the fifth floor and you'd have to be very tall or in a
tree. Okay. We say, or we just take it by. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thank you for listening and for questing with us.